[Musique]
le coronavirus le cosy de 19
un nom que la planète entière désormais
connaît et redoute bonjour à tous et
bienvenue dans le grand jt des
territoires nous sommes au coeur donc
d'une crise mondiale d'une pandémie qui
n'épargne à ce jour aucun pays et qui
inquiète les populations d'un bout à
l'autre de la planète avec les
télévisions locales de france de la tnt
répartis sur tout le territoire avec la
presse quotidienne régionale aussi et
malgré le confinement conformément aux
gestes barrières préconisées par le
gouvernement
eh bien nous sommes mobilisés pour
continuer de vous informer durant cette
crise mondiale qui fait chaque jour vous
savez de nouvelles victimes
c'est le cas dans la région grand est où
la situation s'aggrave le président de
la république manuel macron s'est rendu
sur place à mulhouse où les hôpitaux
connaissent un afflux continu de malades
c'est également le cas dans les ehpad où
la situation est très critique vous le
savez particulièrement vous allez voir
dans le département des vosges où cet
établissement de cordy mon une commune
moyenne du canton de la bresse en
lorraine connaît un très grand nombre de
victimes
la situation est dramatique les équipes
de viarouge sur place nous décrivent la
situation regarder il est depuis ce
lundi au coeur de l'actualité depuis en
fait un communiqué de l'agencé régionale
de santé qui confirme ici à l'ehpad le
coup à roche de cornimont 21 décès en
lien possible avec le comique 19 depuis
sa mise en confinement la directrice de
l'établissement à accepter pour nous de
revenir sur justement ces mesures mises
en place par les équipes soignantes
depuis début mars
on a fermé le 2 mars au soir et donc les
repas sont distribués en chambre fin des
animations aussi à cette même date pour
que l'on puisse limiter en fait la
propagation des vieilles malgré tout en
fait le virus était là bien avant
lou était dans la bergerie bien avant et
il a pu se disperser voilà je pense
qu'il suffit d'une personne un symptôme
à cliquer pour pour le propager au sein
de l'établissement est mal était fait et
si les pattes de cornimont est
aujourd'hui celui qui au niveau national
présente pour le moment le bilan le plus
lourd il pourrait être juste un peu en
avance par rapport aux autres
glissement qui selon un médecin
intervenant au courage ne sont pas à
l'abri malgré le confident part d'un cas
qui est suspecté un confinement qui
arrive tout de suite derrière et le
temps de l'incubation plainte de café
bride qui fleurissent alors que le
confinement est déjà à l'oeuvre donc si
vous voulez le confinement il est là
pour éviter une sur dissémination et la
dissémination et déjà opéré vous verrez
que l'avenir montrera que de toute façon
le même cas d'école appliquée à d'autres
structures donnera le même type de bilan
effroyable morbide
sachant que toute façon les étudiants de
15 à 30% mortalité dans les structures
fermées ya fort à parier que sauf à
avoir des autos testing & d et des
possibilités d'identification plus
rapides qu'eux on arrivera on court
après le virus ce mardi en tout cas la
préfecture a distribué des masques de
protection dans tous les ehpad vosgien
ou d'ailleurs les mesures de confinement
ont été renforcé les mesures de
protection et de barrières ont été
renforcées un guide leur a été adressée
ce matin à tous les étages du
département on leur demande une création
d'un secteur dédié qu'ovide lisez-le
m'enchante de tous les résidents mais ça
souvent ça a été ça avait été fait on a
quand même des établissements qui ne
sont pas touchés plus tôt je m'emploie
dire aussi c'est que le virus semble
toucher les ehpad un peu de façon
sporadique
donc ça on ne sait pas trop
obligatoirement comme en mai a été
confirmé par exemple ce week end à
neufchâteau alors que le confinement mis
en oeuvre on retourne du côté de
cornimont où la municipalité est bien
évidemment mobilisé à l' écoute des
besoins du coin rouge mais aussi de
l'ensemble des habitants de la commune
avec la mise en place dès ce mardi d'un
service de livraison assurée par les
services de la mer
on a décidé de contacter toutes les
personnes de la commune lorsqu'on trouve
les coordonnées téléphoniques pour
savoir si tout va bien et on met en
place un système de portage de soi de
médicaments soit de repas soit de pain
on est en train de médecins avec les
commerçants donc les personnes
intéressées qui ne veulent pas sortir
qu'ils ne veulent pas prendre de risques
qui ont bien raison pour ont appelé leur
boulanger leur bouche et leur pharmacien
met en place ces dispositifs pour pour
livrer les personnes qui le souhaiteront
et pour aller encore un peu plus loin
dans la démarche et mutualiser les
moyens la municipalité de cornimont doit
maintenant se rapprocher des communes
voisines
la bresse veine tron et soul / / vous
êtes vous venez de le voir la région
grand est est l'une des plus touchées
résultat dans les villes de mulhouse et
de colmar les infrastructures médicales
ne suffisent plus notre partenaire de
ouest france nous apprend sur son site
internet que pour désengorger les
hôpitaux l'armée de l'air a dû procéder
à des évacuations sanitaires vers brest
et quimper en bretagne tous les détails
de cette opération d'accueil des malades
vers l'ouest du pays sont racontées sur
le site de ouest france.fr comme vous
pouvez le voir sur cet écran et puis
autre opération inédite dans notre pays
c'est même une première européenne le
site de nos partenaires actus.fr nous
indique lui qu'un tgv médicalisé va être
affectées afin d'évacuer 30 patients
depuis cette fois les villes de
strasbourg et de mulhouse toujours vers
l'ouest vers des régions et des centres
hospitaliers moins impactés par cette
crise sanitaire du donc au covit 19
bien sûr cette crise le personnel
soignant est en première ligne
le président de la république emmanuel
macron a d'ailleurs annoncé un vaste
plan d'investissement et de
revalorisation des carrières pour ces
personnels qui sont saluées chaque soir
par des millions de français qui les
applaudissent et les soutiennent souvent
sur leur balcon
un soutien dont ils ont largement besoin
écouter ce témoignage de l'un d'entre
eux un interne des hôpitaux de la somme
recueillie par charles yzerman de wéo la
chaîne tnt des hauts de france anthony
martin lance un appel aux français pour
lui la population n'a pas pris
conscience du danger de l'épidémie du
coronavirus on est tous face à la mer
comme ça on voit la mer qui se retire
progressivement
et puis on voit la vague voit le tsunami
qui montrent la face qui sa prof qui
s'approche de manière inéluctable et on
sait qu'on va le prendre dans la gueule
on a beau construire la digue la plus
haute possible
tout va dépendre de la taille de la
vague tout va dépendre de la taille de
la vague et la taille de la baguette
dépend de vous vous demande pas de
comprendre pourquoi il faut se confiner
franchement on vous demande pas de
comprendre pourquoi on vous demande de
vous confier c'est tout laisser nos être
un peu paternaliste pour une fois et
vous dire que nous on s'est donc c'est
ce que ça va donner
on sait à quel point c'est grave on sait
ce qu'il faut faire il faut vous
confiner le travail de cet interne se
multiplient à chaque entorse au
règlement la main sur le coeur il parle
sans ménagement franchement je me sens
insulté et je suis pas le seul à avoir
cette impression parce que c'est comme
si on nous disait démerdez vous gérez
comme vous pouvez gérer cette crise
sauver nos vies mais ne nous empêchait
pas de vivre comme on a envie de vivre
ne nous empêchait pas de sortir de chez
nous et non ça fonctionne pas comme ça
ça marche pas comme ça
cette arrogance et peut-être un peu
française était un peu dans notre adn
mais dangereuse cette arrogance et elle
fera mortels cette arrogance peut-être
pour vous peut-être pour vos proches
pour quelqu'un altra mortel parce que ça
ne fait que monter la taille de la vague
et vous aurez beau nous applaudir tous
les soirs ça sert à rien on se sentira
insulter tout pareil le message de cette
interne est clair écouter les
spécialistes et respecter les règles de
confinement toujours sur ce sujet
catastrophique du manque de masques pour
éviter la propagation du virus dans
notre pays
regardez cette initiative cette fois ci
elle nous vient de bretagne
en effet le mois dernier armor lux
envisager la construction de nouveaux
locaux à quimper
la crise du coronavirus a stoppé net les
projets de cette enseigne bretonne
les magasins sont maintenant fermés à
quimper dans l' usine de production 500
des 580 salariés sont aujourd'hui en
chômage partiel
cette situation n'a pas empêché les
dirigeants de se lancer quand même dans
la confection de masques pour lutter
contre le coc vite 19-25 couturières ont
remis le chemin de lusine et réalise
deux mille pièces par jour
on écoute michel guéguen le directeur
général d'armor lux au micro de
christophe bouchet de tébéo la chaîne du
groupe le télégramme
en bretagne les établissements publics
vous avez aussi les les mairies qui nous
appellent mais aussi des particuliers
qui dit nous demandent quelques rouleaux
de tricot pour fabriquer à la maison des
masques et venir en aide d affirmer hier
des aides soignantes qui connaissent pas
ce fait réviser qui compte trois couches
loin deux couches de coton coton peigné
bien sûr et puis au milieu tu as une
couche polyester donc ce sont des
malassis on a deux tailles des femmes
une taille homme qui voit et donc ce
sont des masques qui sont lavables à 30
degrés sont des bières qu'ils sont très
polyvalents donc chaud passé de la
marine air au bike charbagh lutte c'est
un problème nos boutiques ne ne
distribuent plus les vendre nos produits
donc je crois que si nous n'avions pas
eu ces masques à faire nous serions
probablement chômage partiel dans ce
pack oublier autres secteurs des plus
impactés par cette crise sans précédent
le tourisme c'est le cas notamment dans
les territoires et les départements
d'outre-mer nous allons nous rendre
maintenant en martinique où 98% des
hôtels ont récemment fermé et où les
derniers clients attendent sur place le
rapatriement nos confrères de vie à atv
martinique ont rencontré des touristes
vous allez voir pour le moins
déboussolés des vacances de rêve qui
tourne au cauchemar
ces touristes doivent écourter leur
séjour en martinique à cause du court
aux navires us mais avant de pouvoir
partir ils doivent respecter le
confinement on se colle pas les uns aux
autres et puis
on attend cette façon c'est ça ou rester
enfermé sur notre terrasse devant la
chaux de kochi devant la chambre donc
oui on a trouvé la pelouse parce qu on a
fait la plage quand même à on a un peu
trop d a évité à chaque fois donc du
coup maintenance mais sur la pelouse et
puis voilà des activités sont suspendues
la piscine n'est plus accessible l'hôtel
dans lequel il séjourne doit
exceptionnellement fermé ses portes la
semaine prochaine pour respecter les
règles de sécurité
les prochaines étapes là c'est d'arriver
au bout de tous les hébergements que
nous avons encore à leur da l'heure
d'aujourd'hui d'aider nos clients à
trouver des billets d'avion pour partir
plus tôt donc là on a énormément de
départ entre aujourd'hui samedi et
dimanche
dimanche il n'y restera peut-être une
toute petite dizaine d'appartements qui
partiront entre lundi et mardi prochain
je le souhaite pour nos clients des
mesures difficiles à vivre pour les
visiteurs mais certains comprennent
malgré tout dans cet autre hôtel de
sainte-luce pour l'instant tout va bien
cernant le confinement
de guadeloupe peut on est arrivé il ya
deux jours ici on s'est bien occupé de
nous il ya pas de problème on a une
autre voiture de location pour venir à
l'hôtel
ensuite le confinement on a un petit
balcon et bien on y vient très bien pour
l'instant ça se passe plutôt bien
qu'est-ce qu'on a la possibilité d'aller
à la piscine
donc tout va bien on n'est pas trop
concerné encore par le par le virus
les conditions d'accueil devrait
rapidement évoluer la direction de
l'hôtel a reçu des consignes et services
seront réorganisés sur et nos clients
baliser un minimum de repas par jour
donc on a mis une organisation pour cela
en place après il avait accès aux
piscines jusqu'à aujourd'hui où depuis y
est on a reçu ce matin j'ai reçu un
message leur disant de fermer les
piscines que ce n'est pas n'est plus en
capacité des contrôles et donc nous
fermons les piscines ce matin ils
allaient jusqu alors à la plage qui a
été interdite à quelques jours puisqu'il
confinement qui a été mis en place
coup dur pour le tourisme alors que la
haute saison semblait bien lancé le
court aux navires us n'épargne donc
aucun secteur économique comme vous
l'avez vu les ans trouvés sont fortement
impactées par cette crise qui les a
prises de court elle cherche du coût des
solutions concrètes qui puissent les
aider
et dans ce gîte et nous nous sommes
intéressés à cette initiative du
business club de france le mague échos
des entreprises qui tentent d'être un
relais concret entre elles dans cette
période critique michel picaud vous vous
présenter chaque semaine cette émission
qui a pour but d'abord de rester en
contact avec toutes ces entreprises qui
connaissent ou vous connaître des
difficultés
c'est bien cela bonjour serré le bonjour
à toutes et à tous oui malheureusement
de nombreuses entreprises dans nos
territoires sont à l'arrêt
malheureusement pour certaines d'entre
elles les temps sont difficiles mais
vous le savez chaque semaine sur votre
télévision locale
nous tentons de vous apporter des
réponses et le médiateur des entreprises
car pelouse est avec nous je rappelle
que la médiation des entreprises est un
service gratuit pour venir en aide aux
entrepreneurs en difficulté
alors concernant les délais de paiement
par exemple sont mal qui touche la
france
on n'a pas besoin de la crise pour
s'orner de très mauvais payeurs dans ce
pays mais sachez qu'un comité de crise a
été créée
dénoncer justement les mauvais payeurs
et encourager les entreprises qui jouent
le jeu
alors n'hésitez pas à saisir la
médiation si vous avez des factures en
souffrance et où que vous soyez dans le
territoire il ya toujours un médiateur
là où vous êtes
il ya beaucoup d'autres problèmes vous
me direz vous attention notamment on
parle en ce moment des décalages des
charges fiscales et sociales
ce n'est qu'un décalage le saurons payer
tôt ou tard donc fait très attention
et puis il ya des pme qui travaillent
qui continuent d'être là exemple à
neuvic en dordogne
laurent de verlan je fabrique du caviar
même si ce n'est pas trop le moment de
se faire plaisir avec le caviar et bien
les poissons en élevage il faut bien
s'en occuper donc ils travaillent et
puis dernier point cette période une
vingtaine de personnes a décidé d'offrir
tous ces masques de protection pour
fabriquer le cas eh bien tous ces
masques ont été offertes au personnel de
santé de la région
laurent devin revanche oui en effet nous
utilisons des masques pour l'hygiène
qu'on appelle des masques chirurgicaux
qui sont utiles pour travailler
proprement dans un laboratoire ou non
mais les fesses comme une autre on a eu
pas mal de demandes locales d un ehpad
des associations d'infirmières qui nous
ont dit ce que vous auriez pas troué on
a fait notre montée en effet il était
tout à fait aussi pour nous de nous
défaire de l'image qu'ont offert à la
mairie de neuvic qui les a répartis
entre la rs qui les anglais récente de
chanter et puis des des petits centres
pour les handicapés pour les infirmières
des ambulances
c'est la région qui ont pu en bénéficier
voilà donc une très très belle
initiative en peut tous faire quelque
chose dans cette période de crise osons
et avançant merci michel picot je
rappelle que vous présentez le business
club de france des entreprises le mag
échos des territoires qu'on peut
retrouver en diffusion sur l'ensemble
des chaînes tnt locale et bien entendu
en numérique sur internet
très vite comment vous vivez vous cette
crise et ces situations parfois si
difficile
vous savez le gouvernement à annoncer de
nouvelle mesure encore plus restrictive
d'ailleurs à nouveau document pour vous
permettre d'exercer des activités
limitée est accessible dorénavant sur
les sites internet notamment ceux de la
presse quotidienne régionale et parmi
ces nouvelles mesures gouvernementales
figurent la fermeture des marchés en
plein air sauf dérogation qui peuvent
être faites par les maires commencent
approvisionner en produits frais c'est
l'inquiétude de bon nombre de français
aujourd'hui à saint-just-saint-rambert
dans la loi vous allez le voir on a
trouvé une alternative qui mérite le
détour regardez ce reportage de nos
partenaires de tl7 à saint-etienne il
est 10 heures sur la place du marché à
saint-just-saint-rambert les forains
sont bien là
quelques clients également arpentent les
allées mais ne traîne pas on vient ici
faire ses courses de première nécessité
et c'est tout pas de place aux
discussions entre passants l'ambiance
est à la fois plaisante et calme où tout
est étonnant aujourd'hui le calme en
règle générale le souk c'était étonnant
morceau nécessaires face on est bien
obligés d'assurer le minimum
l'italien a mangé quoi voilà pistons des
privés de bien des choses
d'habitude je me sers tout seul la jeune
femme servir je vais attendre comme
celle des habitudes ont changé
plus rien n'est comme avant les
maraîchers portent des masques et des
gants
mais le principal pour ces
professionnels c'est d'être là et de
vendre ce qu'ils peuvent
on met tout notre chance de l'autre côté
parce que si on tombe malade on pourra
plus travailler aussi donc de ses 70 % à
80 % de notre chiffre d'affaires nous il
faut surtout pas qu'ils nous analyse de
marché parce qu'on savait pas ce que tu
vois j'ai dit jack sock d'avancement de
semaine en semaine et essaient des
denrées périssables à montbrison aussi
ces images de foules sur le plus beau
marché de france sont bien loin le maire
a maintenu le marché mais pas question
d'attirer les foules toutes les
précautions sont prises
la preuve obama nador et un barriérage
du marché ou le cas échéant il y avait
trop de monde
limiter ce monde qu'on pouvait le père
du père marché aujourd'hui on a même
prévu de garder les victimes au sol
pour les forains les points souvent de
pâtes et de plus de 2 m
l'idée est bien de permettre à des gens
de pouvoir acheter un mollet sont trop
de riz à montbrison comme ailleurs les
maires se réserve la possibilité de
fermer les marchés
si la fréquentation devenait trop
importante cette crise mobilise aussi
les associations qui tant bien que mal
elle aussi et tente de venir en aide aux
plus démunis
malgré le confinement une solidarité si
importante dans ces moments qui fait
chaud au coeur c'est le cas vous allez
le voir du secours populaire qui
poursuit son travail sans relâche et que
tv 78 a suivi dans les yvelines regardez
nous on n'a pas des manettes et à des
enfants aussi celle inclinera que j'aime
reçoivent aujourd'hui un message pour me
confirmer la distribution des denrées
alimentaires
et j'aime m'y attendais même pas un
soulagement du côté des bénéficiaires
l'antenne de trappes continue ses
actions auprès de 100 familles ce
jour-là une demi douzaine de bénévoles
s'est rassemblée pour distribuer des
sourires malgré les masques et un autre
engagement pour certains normalement moi
je suis surtout des vacances des enfants
et les familles mais là dans l'urgence
il faut des bras donc il faut donner un
coup de main parce que malgré la crise
les gens continuent de manger les gens
qui sont difficultés sont doublement
difficulté mais les équipes ont dû
s'adapter mise en place de règles
strictes des lignes au sol à ne pas
dépasser et de nouvelles techniques de
distribution
ici les bénévoles sont passés au drive
on a effectivement fait décoller plus
gros parce qu'on n'est pas sûr d'être en
capacité d'avoir assez de bénévoles pour
maintenir les distributions parce que
beaucoup des bénévoles sont des
personnes âgées et à risque et donc
confinées chez elles
l'ensemble des bénévoles portent des
masques des gants et on a dû l hydro
alcooliques à disposition avec des l'eau
de javel de l'alcool ménagé pour pouvoir
vraiment tenté au mieux d'éradiquer ce
virus et des distributions qui continue
dans les yvelines comme ici à saint cyr
l'école
le secours populaire d yves il réfléchit
aussi apportèrent l'accompagnement
scolaire par téléphone ou
visioconférence
ce virus n'est pas absolument personne à
vous en avez peut-être entendu parler de
nombreuses célébrités des chefs d'état
même sont aussi atteints par le cos vide
c'est le cas du prince charles
d'angleterre mais aussi du prince albert
de monaco qui malgré tout reste aux
commandes de sa principauté et s'est
adressé aux monégasques bien sûr mais
également au reste du monde
il est confiné chez lui mais continue de
gérer sa principauté et de coordonner
l'organisation de vie de cet état
princier membres de l'onu johan rouquet
pour monte-carlo riviera avec des images
de monaco info
nous débutons cette nouvelle émission de
monte-carlo rivera n'évoquons
l'actualité le coronavirus comme le
monde entier la principauté de monaco
est impacté par la crise sanitaire
le prince albert ii a été testé positif
aux convives 19
pour autant le souverain se veut
rassurant sur son état de santé continue
de travailler à temps
aveyron discours le prince a souhaité
remercier le personnel de santé en
première ligne et s'est montré confiant
sur l'avenir de monaco chers
compatriotes chers résidents chaire
salariés de la principauté
notre pays confrontée à l'une des pires
crises sanitaires de son histoire
bien avant que l'épidémie d'e.coli 19
n'atteignent l'europe
mon gouvernement et les services de
l'état s'y sont préparés ils ont pris
les dispositions nécessaires pour y
faire face
après avoir pu ralentir efficacement sa
propagation
l'épidémie à l'instar de l'ensemble des
pays européens menacent de progresser en
principauté nous entamons donc désormais
une phase d' endiguement du virus comme
les régions voisines
nous sommes prêts j'ai confiance en
notre système de santé dans ses
infrastructures et surtout en ces femmes
et ces hommes qui exercent leur travail
dans des conditions difficiles
je veux leur rendre hommage je veux
adresser mes plus vifs remerciements en
mon nom et en celui de la population un
ensemble des personnels privés et
publics de la santé monégasque qui
travaillent sans relâche et remplissent
leurs missions sous une pression
constante est grandissante
un effort rendue possible grâce au
soutien des personnels de la force
publique et de la sûreté publique
je tiens également à saluer
l'implication totale de la mairie pour
ses actions en faveur de nos aînés et de
nos plus jeunes enfants les services
communaux se sont mobilisés sans réserve
dans leur mission de proximité
je n'oublie pas l'engagement de la croix
rouge monégasque de ses bénévoles et des
entités associative il est réconfortant
de constater le réel élan de solidarité
qui se manifestent spontanément je pense
plus particulièrement aux propositions
d'entr'aide publiées sur les réseaux
sociaux
nous constatons bien que ces moments et
particuliers prendre soin de soi c'est
aussi prendre soin des autres
je suis confiant en l'avenir je suis
confiant en la solidité de nos
infrastructures sanitaires
je sais que mon pays peut s'appuyer sur
son histoire ses institutions et la
solidité de son modèle économique et
social
mes chers compatriotes chers résidents
cher salariés notre pays a déjà au cours
de son passé dû affronter de grandes
difficultés les a toujours su remonter
grâce à un esprit de solidarité et
d'entraidé au sein de notre communauté
ce n'est qu'ensemble est uni que nous
arriverons à vaincre cette épreuve qui
dans notre histoire récente n'a pas
d'équivalent d augmenter viva mon écot
pour conclure ce journal un regard sur
les réseaux sociaux maintenant de
nombreuses et parfois jolie initiatives
ont vu le jour depuis le début de cette
crise du coronavirus des actions de
solidarité qui vous sont résumées par
nos confrères de boîtes à images
regardez ce zapping
[Musique]
les maires docteur en gardien el
soignantes infirmières agents de
sécurité ont mis le raison de rester
confiné mais leurs propres raisons peut
pas laisser tomber
qu'ils nous donnent
selon
répondu à la demande de la commission
européenne pour fabriquer en urgence à
destination des hôpitaux des masques et
des ventilateurs
on a une dizaine de machines et pour
pouvoir rapidement utilisés si besoin
est pour cette opération
[Musique]
donc l'idée toute simple c'est de
rejoindre un groupe facebook qui
s'appelle asseoir une musique 3 et agglo
et là nous déciderons de musique en
commun que nous allons diffuser à 19h30
à nos fenêtres
[Musique]
attention message très important
on entre dans la deuxième semaine de
confinement le corps d'un virus est
partout en europe utile de l'épidémie
n'est pas encore arrivé donc on doit
encore tous âges et un meilleur moyen
pour éviter la propagation pour éviter
de saturer encore plus les hôpitaux et
pour protéger nos familles on l'a déjà
beaucoup dit on vous demande de rester
chez on compte sur vous sauver des vies
restez chez vous restez chez vous restez
chez vous voilà merci d'avoir suivi
cette édition du grand jt des
territoires merci à tv 78 dans les
yvelines qui nous a accueillis sur son
plateau
on se retrouve bien sûr pour les
prochaines éditions sur l'ensemble des
chaînes tnt régionale de france et sur
tv5 monde et bien sûr
bon courage à tous à bientôt
[Musique]